scientists are working on covid vaccine
you can drink finally you can okay
finally so let me read this to you a new
type of X this is a CNET story a new
type of vaccine called mucosal vaccines
which can take uh can be taken as they
Swish and swallow oral vaccine or nasal
vaccine is being developed and could be
available within a couple years the
qyndr as if we need another acronym to
remember oral vaccine developed by the
U.S specialty formulations has completed
its phase one clinical trial and is
waiting on funding to proceed to more
advanced trials the vaccine is designed
to survive the digestive system and
induce the appropriate response to
clinical trial results from New Zealand
are promising and offer hope that the
vaccine will be available a viable
option for protection against the
current covid-19 variants however in
order to get the vaccine to be Advanced
uh to additional clinical trials funding
from investors is needed okay so if you
guys wanting to invest this is the story
from CNET you can go look into it when
you you hear something like this what do
you think about you know for for me if
this is a business model you know like a
CBD okay or or THC or you say so now
what are we doing let's let's talk about
it from Strictly the business model
standpoint on what Pfizer is doing what
these guys are doing
I don't smoke weed I probably should but
I don't smoke weed okay it'd be fun to
watch I don't drink coffee thank God I
don't yeah you don't want me to drink
coffee I shouldn't drink Red Bull
monster what else is there any of that
stuff don't don't get it close to me
okay one time we tested my urine and it
they said this is the closest thing to
Red Bull that's what they say that's a
joke you don't need more but I don't
need any of it right but you know wheat
is a different story okay so anyways so
this guy's like well you know we're
selling weed oil now coal hey this guy
says you're having lower back pains try
the CBD oil to put on your lower back
like does that mean my back is getting
high what does it mean your spine hey if
you're if you try these gummy bears okay
or try these cookies or try this right
anyways what's the point
if it's legal and you're finding
creative ways for people to be able to
buy that guess what credit goes to to
the team the seller that is getting
creative so if vaccine is one method is
what shot and they wanting to go on this
side from the standpoint of innovation
on how to get it into the system fine
you can tell them good for the team that
thought about this now the other thing
you have to pose and ask the question is
level of trust how comfortable people
are about it is it something where the
timing is good right now to announce it
is it becoming to the point where
everybody is in the camp of yes I'll
take it I don't know what are your
thoughts what are your thoughts I think
I think the fact and from what we saw
that they said yes I don't think I've
ever said this please raise Vinnie's
audio by about five percent are you
serious that's the first person did you
guys hear that because he lowered it by
ten percent
but Pat think about it as a business
standpoint what what they did with fauci
and everybody in the government they
scared the out of everybody yeah so
and you we all know these type of people
they're like another booster give it to
me give it to me give it to me I give
them props because now they they have
their their loyal brainwashed customers
now just another delivery system like
you said if they say there's a vaccine
shampoo I guarantee you people will just
they the more the better and then and as
we're finding out Pat the the the the
the science hasn't been tested long
enough to find out if it's gonna affect
you which I think we're seeing that
people are dropping left and right they
don't give a just give them more
give them more I give them props as the
seller but as the people people need to
still wake the house what are you
thinking uh well there's two things I
see here I see a startup business in
biotech that's talking about clinical
trials Advanced trials in other words
not operation warp speed doing something
over the course of time that that
medications and vaccines have been
tested in history not this BS
acceleration that we had along with
amnesty the vaccine makers I see that on
one side the other side I see a glaring
hole in this business model if I was an
investor I'm sitting there I would say
so you think there's going to be a
long-term market for covid vaccines so
you think covet is here to stay and all
the mutations are here to stay you'd
think there's a long-term market and I
would be sitting there thinking there
saying
wow you know if there's really a
long-term market for this then unlike
swine flu went bird flu one remember
hhv whatever it was bird flu it kind of
came and went because
there was there was
um you know it ran the cycle it ran the
human cycle and what have we heard about
swine bird flu southeast Asia
gone yep it's not gone but we don't hear
about it anymore because it is not
affecting the mass of society so I look
at this and I say so there's really
going to be a long-term Market on covid
you know are we the Lab Rats somebody
out there mutating this and so that they
can sell product we're finding out that
they are though you know last night
we're sitting at this wonderful event
with Adam and um so sitting across this
guy who was a follower of the podcast
great guy 37 years old successful guy
solid guy good looking guy and he says
you know Patrick 99 of what you say I
sit down I say yep I agree yeah he's
probably listening yep I agree yep I
agree but there's the one part where
you're not for dmts and not for
psychedelics and all this stuff I'm like
dude we gotta get Patrick on
psychedelics I remember I've never been
a drug guy Never Smoke Weed never did
this never did that 34 years old I went
through a bad breakup first time I did
you know psychedelics it was
life-changing for me I said that's
awesome man very happy for you so then
the guy to my left is like your
personality I know you probably would
never do psychedelics but maybe you
would it's like okay here we go so now
I'm invited to a party where everybody
wants to wants to get me to do
psychedelics okay great fantastic
another a great party that everybody
wants me to do something so then this
girl shows up hi hi
oh two eyes so look you know we're
trying to get Patrick to do psychedelics
so why don't you try psychedelics yeah
she says um uh do you uh follow science
I said define that no no she literally
says she says do you follow signs yeah I
said can you define that because it's
been a little bit confusing yeah it's
just no science I said well if I have to
trust the science that means I have to
take vaccine and no I don't trust that
science but what do you mean by science
she says well let me ask you a different
question then
do you trust the FDA no
she says um uh what do you believe in I
said so what do you believe in she says
no I'm asking a new question I said now
I want to know what you believe in well
I believe uh in spirits college and I
believe in uh you know certain what'd
she say she said some stuff like this
like you know and that that energy if I
can't have my energy I can give it to I
said I agree with that and I'm saying
that so I agree with that she says so
now I'm going to ask the question what
do you believe in I said uh I believe in
God I believe in good relationships I
believe in never compromising your
values and principles that fully believe
in your convictions don't convince
everybody to bind to your vision not
everybody's going to understand your
vision and then she says well you know
as she says so you would never uh you
would probably never do and she says
what if I bring you an expert that gives
you all the data and all the Articles
all of it that proves that psychedelics
are good for you I said I'd love to have
him debate somebody who's a doctor and a
scientist who has articles that that
scientist has not showing yeah that
opposes why psychedelics maybe aren't
good for you and I would listen to that
debate and I would make up my mind at
the end she said you just sound
close-minded oh God and then Adam asked
a question and says so tell me about you
you know Adam's trying to be his sweet
self so he said so tell me about
yourself
so are you married do you have kids or I
don't know what you ask are you married
she says you would never ask a man that
question and then Adam says I actually
would and I said all the time I said why
are you so defensive yeah so she is now
turning red oh God so I'm talking to my
boy here I'm having a really good time
with this guy because we're talking
about trying to figure people's
personalities based on when they're born
psychedelic guy or this guy's a chill
guy he's a guy with Deepak
really enjoying him he's he's half
Persian half Venezuelan half all this
stuff literally yeah great conversation
and I'm getting up I'm like okay Adam
I'm gonna take off man I'm gonna go home
she says oh I'm so sorry did I say I
said no yes listen my life is too great
for you to upset me thank you so much it
was great talking to you I'm going to
take off and the entire time was like
trying to now redeem herself from this
high quality here's the point she seemed
like a sweetheart
she's just been fed because she's from
what was your Maryland Venture Capital
she travels six months all this other
stuff right in that world you trust
science
in the world and a life I've lived you
trust debate you trust people debating
because if you've lived my life that's
what I trust I trust two experts who are
a hundred percent convinced they're
right let them hash it up and one of the
things I said last time I don't know if
you remember this I said I said uh you
know what we've learned the last two and
a half years she said what I said
experts using data have forced all of us
to believe in what they're believing in
and they've divided the world so I don't
trust experts that use certain data they
want to choose to validate their
arguments I kind of want to see both
sides I like debate okay so if you
enjoyed this club you want to see
another one click here to watch another
clip and if you want to take advantage
the latest gold Signature Series
products that just came out we have a
bunch of new merch that's out this is a
color changing mug when you drink coffee
that lion turns into a real lion and
then we have hoodies with vitamin gold
on it the gold Signature Series hat
shirts I'm an entrepreneur anyways we
have a lot of items they're selling out
if if you want to take advantage of the
gold Signature Series click here place
your order Sports your right taming gear
and tag us with the hashtag
valuetainment
[Music]